mais on est dans la merde
simplement et moi je pourrais pas
travailler deux ans de plus hein c'est
pas possible là actuellement j'ai 47 ans
je me lève les doigts ils sont paralysés
le matin parce que vous savez on pince
d'accord on a les coudes on a des
fourmis les genoux les chevilles la
pénibilité chez nous elle est juste elle
est juste importante très importante
dans beaucoup de métiers mais là je
parle du mien et le dos on prend
énormément aussi dans le coup on respire
aussi quand on est derrière le camion
quand on est ripeur on respire des
produits nocifs
voilà donc c'est c'est pour tout ça
qu'on se bat
aujourd'hui pourquoi aujourd'hui vous
allez voir va vous montrer regardez dans
le 17e arrondissement regardez dans le
17e pour montrer la situation
catastrophique à Paris regarder voilà
regardez regardez regardez dans le 12e
arrondissement aussi pour mettre la
vidéo regardez ça permet
moi ça me choque ça me choque
c'est notre seul moyen de pression pour
pouvoir faire bouger les choses et j'en
appelle j'en appelle vraiment à Monsieur
Macron si nous écoute vous voulez pas
recevoir les syndicats très bien vous
voulez moi je suis pas dans la politique
je suis pas dans les syndicats je suis
pas le représentant des éboueurs je suis
Ludovic françaischet et je suis neutre
donc si vous voulez qu'on en discute il
y a aucun souci on y va on fonce et si
ça peut changer les choses pour l'avenir
et pour des millions de gens je serai le
plus heureux du monde et je pourrais
mourir tranquille regardez on vous a
fait même une compile Tik Tok voilà des
des rues jonchées déchets dans les rues
de Paris c'est incroyable regardez
[Musique]
incroyable et regardez qui dit déchets
dit odeurs très relou si c'est compliqué
si c'est compliqué de filmer les odeurs
certains habitants filment au moins tous
les déchets qu'ils ont en bas de leur
fenêtres c'est dramatique regardez
et regardez pas de passe-droit même les
poubelles du président n'ont pas été
ramassées regardez dans l'Élysée
a fait partie des arrondissements ou les
poubelles ne sont pas ramassistes dans
le 8e arrondissement que se trouve le
palais de l'Elysée Emmanuel Macron
pour le chef de l'été les poubelles ne
sont pas ramassées devant le palais de
l'écouter
qui tourne c'est incroyable vous allez
voir par exemple il y a aussi des des
personnalités qui ont fait des confirmer
les rues de Paris organique regardez il
était en balade à vélo tranquillou
regardez
il y a pas que ça bien sûr il y a tout
les commerçants aussi qui n'en peuvent
plus forcément cette situation exaspère
des millions de gens qui doivent vivre
et marcher en plein milieu des déchets
c'est sale il y a une odeur très très
nauséabonde regardez
ceux qui sub
issent pour eux pour nous les
restaurateurs parce que du coup nous on
a quand même plein de déchets
d'emballage même si on essaie de faire
attention ce qui stockent leurs
poubelles dans leur restaurant ou dans
des cours intérieures craignent
l'arrivée des nuisibles et les problèmes
d'hygiène
[Musique]
et puis il y a des poubelles des gens
qui habitent au dessus qui vont aussi
qui commencent à s'entasser juste
derrière et voilà les
souris vont commencer à venir et moins
de clients sur la terrasse de cette
brasserie on commence à ne plus vendre
ses tables du fait que la vue n'est pas
très
pas très agréable c'est vrai que on voit
des déchets partout c'est incroyable ça
va durer jusqu'à quand cette affaire
alors là pour l'instant ça va aller
jusqu'à mercredi mais
j'ai bien peur que ça continue
jusqu'à ce que il ne retire pas cette
réforme de quoi ça veut dire que l'on
peut avoir les déchets comme ça ça veut
dire que ça va et qu'est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir d'autres tu m'as parlé tu m'as dit
tu pas voulu me dire là tu m'as dit il y
aura peut-être quelque chose d'autre
c'est quoi ouais il y aura peut-être
d'autres choses sinon je peux pas je
peux pas le dire je peux pas je peux pas
mais mais je peux garantir qu'on va pas
rester là vraiment donc il va y avoir
alors je dis bien moi je parle en mon
nom on est bien d'accord et mais j'ai
entendu des choses et il faut vraiment
que les choses
Macron en fait c'est ça le problème tu
peux aller jusqu'à mercredi la dernière
grève elle avait duré 23 jours la
dernière fois
je pars par exemple je lui ai aussi
saluer tous les éboueurs qui sont qui
bloquent les incinérateurs moi j'y vais
demain là j'y vais demain à Évry et je
peux vous garantir que ils vont tenir et
si vous voulez aller les voir allez à
Ivry-sur-Seine elle est leur donner un
coup de main vraiment et il faut savoir
aussi qu'elle est caisse de grève
d'accord faut en parler donc ça fait pas
que moi je pense pas que je pense pas
que je vais les utiliser j'ai des potes
qui font grève ils se retrouvent avec 40
balles les pots je te le dis donc c'est
c'est complet voilà donc une semaine de
travail tu te retrouves avec 40 €, je
peux te dire que ça ça te calme aussi et
c'est c'est je il y a plein de potes
voilà qui m'ont dit que c'était les
caisses de grève c'est voilà c'est c'est
c'est pas fou euh Nelly Garnier
conseillère de Paris alors il a dit ça
va durer plus que mercredi quelle est la
solution pourquoi la mer la mer ne
réagit pas Anne Hidalgo nous ce qu'on
demande l'opposition avec Rachida Dati
c'est qu'on demande un service minimum
de la collecte de déchets pourquoi parce
que
le fait que le droit de grève mais à
Paris du fait d'une situation qui est
complètement dégradée déjà en temps
normal en matière de propreté ça crée
des problèmes de sécurité ça crée des
problèmes de santé publique si vous
voulez quand vous faites une opération
ponctuelle dans une ville qui est propre
qui bien entretenu il y a pas de
problème enfin la rigueur c'est
compliqué mais on peut l'accepter mais
quand vous le faites dans une ville où
vous avez déjà deux fois plus de règles
d'habitants bien sûr ça donne beaucoup
de monde dans la rue en ce moment et
quelque chose qui est problématique
parce que les rats ils remontent dans
les appartements parce que vous avez
aussi des problèmes de sécurité parce
que les poubelles elles sont sur les
passages piétons elle déborde devant les
écoles donc il peut y avoir des chutes
il peut y avoir des débuts d'incendie et
donc on peut pas laisser les Parisiens
dans cette situation et ce qui est
encore vraiment ce qui est insupportable
pour les Parisiens aujourd'hui c'est que
la saleté du quotidien c'est qu'à la
saleté du quotidien de du temps normal
et bien se surajoute ces situations
exceptionnelles et là il y a un moment
vous savez qu'il y a quand même vous
savez quand même qu'il y a eu plus de il
y a eu 260 000 Parisiens qui ont quitté
Paris en me disant il y a un moment
c'est plus jouable ce qui va se passer
c'est que l'immobilier à Paris va
baisser parce que là c'est trop et que
apparemment un moment ça va peut-être la
faire réagir non mais il y a rien qui
l'a fait réagir
elle fait rien ça l'arrange elle dit que
elle soutient la grève parce que de
toute façon elle a tellement vidé les
caisses que elle sait plus où trouver
l'argent même pour faire appel à des
entreprises d'insertion ou des
entreprises privées qui viendraient tous
les travaux
elle l'a trouvé pour certaines choses
mais le truc pas pour entretenir Paris
et entre faire la qualité de vie pour
les Parisiens je voudrais juste qu'on
revienne sur les déchets juste une
petite minute
mon chéri parce que en fait en France on
est à peu près 66 millions et vous savez
que un habitant en France devinait
combien de déchets il produit par an
tout confondu Sophia Aram
un habitant normal donc un habitant
normal il produit 5 tonnes de déchets
par an mais quand je dis c'est tout
confondu c'est les gravats des meubles
de la nourriture etc tiens on parlait
des rats la nourriture
le rat il est aussi intelligent il sait
que l'être humain il va laisser son son
petit sandwich dans la poubelle et après
il y a un rat qui a fait 100% logique le
samedi
donc il va y aller attends parce que je
contrer la réponse d'Anne Hidalgo la
mère de Paris en même temps on va faire
rentrer Rachman pendant la réponse
regardez
et mon soutien total entier à ce
mouvement social et lorsque cela
concerne en plus des catégories de
personnels de la Fonction publique et du
secteur privé je dis au gouvernement
déjà parlé avec eux déjà essayé de
comprendre ce qui sont en train de vous
dire et puis on parlera de la suite
c'est de la c'est de la politique
elle fait plaisir à personne c'est
n'importe quoi elle est là pour vous
parler soit de la grève soit de la
réforme des retraites soit faire de
l'international soit parler des JO vous
l'entendez parler à un moment du
quotidien des Parisiens jamais Paris se
vide les classes sont fermées parce
qu'il y a plus d'enfants les gens
quittent pareil comme vous dites un
moment on n'a jamais vu ça c'est la
capitale de la France c'est quand même
la capitale de la France pour personne
ne veut y habiter normalement tout le
monde voudrait y habiter tout le monde
et elle le vit comme à chaque fois elles
sont satisfaits elle est Lude moi je
vais vous dire un autre elle a c'est
quand même elle elle a fait campagne en
2020 en disant je vais doubler le budget
propreté pour que Paris soit propre non
mais c'était pour se nettoyer elle
a acheté deux fois plus de Tahiti donc
tout le monde tout le monde oublie enfin
je veux dire c'est pas respecter les
électeurs de faire ça il y a une taxe
sur les ordures ménagères taxe de
balayage vous le savez elle n'est pas
utilisée en entier elle utilise une
partie pour combler la dette parce que
derrière elle va financer des
associations dont elle ne elle n'évalue
jamais l'utilité ou autre elle ne elle
ne respecte pas les Parisiens et c'est
ça les gens vous imaginez ils respectent
les le personnel de la vie qui travaille
les éboueurs les personnels de la
propreté on les respecte seulement
aujourd'hui il faut revoir
l'organisation aussi pour leur permettre
de faire bien leur travail parce que je
vais vous dire c'est moi je trouve ça
terrible de se dire que quand vous
faites ce travail là vous avez pas en
récompense le sourire des Parisiens qui
se disent merci Paris est propre et je
suis content de voir Paris et propre au
contraire c'est sur vous qu'on tombe le
mécontentement des Parisiens et ça c'est
insupportable qu'un Hidalgo parce
qu'elle elle reste enfermée dans le
château elle sort jamais à la rencontre